[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what it's not what is good how you livin
how you feelin the band is back together
Josh is in the middle or here it's
episode 157 Sims got a Miami tan and
we're still on our limit our just got I
don't know why I got makeup yeah well
today it's outer Josh have you missed us
did you miss was yesterday I did miss
you guys yesterday did you enjoy seeing
us on a Leavitt our it was I actually
have a question for you yeah sure
what if Erica's parents been saying
about the podcast lately event any
conversation I have heard anything in
the last week or so so they might not
have listened episode 156 okay I'll ask
them this weekend actually I'll wait and
see if they say anything because if
they're listening they should know that
this conversations happen you're exactly
right
so yes some of the pressure on anyway
back to Leviton yesterday she liked it I
loved it it was awesome the fact that
you became part of the show yesterday to
the point that you see the picture of
him where it said the new Stu gots I did
not see that this new Twitter profile
picture there's the video is this this
is it to me it's my shining moment right
Sims goes on number four moment he says
Tom Brady's number four they all lose
their minds what happens is Sims I'm on
camera for 12 seconds smiling like that
and it just says the news to God and the
true thing is is you saying Tom Brady
number four right it was I felt like I
it was like seeing my child walk for the
first time on ESPN I was like I was like
yes let them know what we do the truth
how great are those people they're as
good as they get I mean they're just
awesome the fans too yes I want to say
this though you know when you meet your
I don't want to say they're my hero
because they're not my hero but like you
meet celebrities or stars wherever and
they always disappoint it was really the
first time in a long time where I felt
like they exceeded my expectations a
hundred percent I didn't have any
expectations going in but they're like
kind and the way they made us feel at
home to the point where you were like
man they're like to kind hey this is
crazy I felt like we were using them
right
we really have work but they were
amazing well they used me too so we're
even
yes there's that I was just gonna say
when Leba tarde on the podcast yesterday
talked about how he never had any
interest in being a national guy that he
always just wanted to be a Miami dude
yes that is the Miami dude mindset he's
not it he does not come off like he is a
famous person or a celebrity no not at
all he just sounds like a guy that loves
what he does and does his radio yep I
mean smart as hell outside the box
singer to watch them orchestrate that
show yep and it's a zoo bro
it's a zoo but it's seven mines in this
organized chaos that they seem to figure
out exactly what they want to do just a
segment before like they know we kind of
want to talk about this but then how do
we make it better well you're talking
about my yachts we got news right now we
you heard it a little bit before or
Pouncy wanted to be released it's cut
it's not much it's Mike Pouncy with the
dolphins that dolphins requesting a
release from Miami and the team is
expected to grant it we have so much
free agency news to get to today but I
will continue to jump in
we have apparently rumors that Jordy
Nelson to the Raiders but Mike bouncy
wants release I just are you now
doubting my Adam GaSe a little bit
people are trying to leave well a little
I mean man pounce he's a good player ah
right III don't get it now listen the
pound seats are not choirboys we know
that so maybe he doesn't want to deal
with that I don't know to me when I also
hear things like that you know we don't
know that full story yet like did they
ask him to maybe renegotiate the
contract or she said that or does his
agent know there's another team out
there or the New England page or you
know somebody out there I'm saying
power-hitting the free agency market
with not a lot of good offensive lineman
having just seen the contract west and
Richburg got and andrew nor well right
there's money to be made and maybe he
doesn't want to play now all right I get
it yeah it is episode 157 truth be told
this is probably episode 557 he's
getting me you know that we did have
that conversation in today you weren't
there for it of why we only count
episodes that we do on Wednesdays no
idea this is the
mothership episode it feels like the
mothership 5757 okay Byron Hunt you have
him on your list no he was an old Giants
linebacker of course you don't know him
I honestly started to look through old
Giants team I'm always gonna come up
with somebody from the old Giants I
other 57s Josh Bynes right the old
Detroit Arizona Cardinals linebacker
nope I don't got him fine so you don't
have them know who else you got gosh man
our man Alexander up in Buffalo yes
Lorenzo Alexander one of the Okafor
yes Okafor thank you for the Saints one
of those Texas Okafor yep
gosh another 57 better lately I'm
getting better
yeah missing any obvious ones three guys
you probably don't know Joe Davis Brown
Keenan Robinson Vincent Ray I mean you
know them the a57 CJ Mosely ah 57 it's a
bad omen is that three guys that are
young and have you know we're gonna see
about their future Eli Harold Noah
Spence and DeMarcus Walker from the
Broncos some Alzheimer guys for me and
Eagles Chris go Cong Rock 257 Steve
Nelson played on the Patriots was a
three-time Pro Bowler shout-out to
Steven Nelson Bart Steven Nelson Ricky
Jackson Hall of Fame linebacker
defensive end for the Saints Sam hit my
dad a lot over the years
another Miami guide Dwight Stephenson
offensive lineman for Miami played seven
seasons but went to the Hall of Fame
another short career but huge impact
right and from Louisville Tom Jackson Oh
big Tom Tom Jackson last game ever
played was Superbowl 21 against my
father Center Olin Kreutz on 57 and a
good one and then three really good
linebackers Moe Lewis Bart Scott and
Clay Matthews all rocked 57 yep man oh
damn I stole even I forgot some of those
before we get to all the free agency
news
the one thing that happened with your
list we put out your top five yeah and
it's probably are the most commented
post on our Instagram and it's one of
the most on Bleacher Report's Instagram
because it's different right number one
you had of course Aaron Rodgers number
two Russell Wilson number three Carson
Wentz number four Tom Brady and number
five Matt Stafford right the number one
comment that we are getting where's drew
Brees which is so surprised by it that
it was Brees why
let me hear Josh why are you surprised I
just thought that the number one thing
we were gonna hear from people was Brady
Wentz but I felt it was overwhelming
briefs the number one was breeze there
were some Roethlisberger's but he was
eight where did you have breeze breeze I
think I'm a 10 exactly 10 yes he is
easily the most he is other than Blake
bortles I think now people are coming
aligned to that people do not see what
you see with Drew Brees yeah why do you
not have him in the top 5 let's just
discuss that now yeah sure
I mean Drew Brees again I'm gonna just
qualify my statement here he's awesome I
mean he's gonna be a first-ballot
hall-of-famer yes now do I think he's as
good as some of those guys in front of
him at this point in his life no I don't
I think those other guys again we can't
we we got to stop taking the team with
the quarterback and the system with the
quarterback and the coach with the
quarterback and thinking it's the same
thing I'm just evaluating the player
okay I don't look at the stats or are
you saying if we were to do a pickup
game right and all the quarterbacks were
in a line you'd rather have deshaun
Watson than drew Brees yes at this point
right now 17 how they performed last
season looking ahead tonight
no no doubt about it again drew Brees
that offense lends itself to numbers all
the time so you can't always look at
numbers alone and it's a great offensive
line it's a great run game and oh yeah
it's one of the greatest offensive minds
in the history of the sport right so
with all those things again this is an
awesome football player but am I gonna
say that he's better than cam or big bed
or Stafford at this point no he could if
you roles were reversed and he had to go
up to Detroit
hey but Detroit Detroit would be worse
than what they are I'm sorry that's just
the way I feel about I like the team
swap you know if ya put Tom Brady and
Aaron Rodgers situation with those wide
receivers in a simple passing game he's
gonna go oh my gosh I didn't meet he's
gonna go yeah I mean he's gonna go what
do I do
I just I guess I have to throw to
covered people all game on there are
four guys in the NFL right I think are
up against it because their offensive
coordinators are so good that sometimes
it's hard to separate them from the
culture and it's whoever is playing
quarterback for Josh McDaniels Sean
McVeigh Kyle Shanahan and Sean P right
those are the four best offensive mind
there's a lot
of other good ones yeah those are the
four best no doubt and you just go there
put in situations to succeed right
and if Carson Wentz had Josh McDaniels
holy crap right I was there for the
Superbowl
I saw how open Chris Hogan was right
Saul how open those guys write an
indictment on Brady he every throw that
was there available to him and I was
amazing
exactly right number three is now number
four is not bad but I am big on this
standpoint I think this might clear it
up for people I'm big on what do you do
when the play is not perfect okay that's
what I'm big on that's that's that's
where a quarterback makes his money I
mean most the quarterbacks in football
can drop back and throw to the first guy
wide open the Josh McDaniels are or Kyle
Shannon or McVeigh or pate or Sean
Payton the play they design that they've
looked all week at and studies bar
almost every quarterback can go oh I can
run that play you're gonna get him wide
open ten yards over the middle no
problem you earn your money when there's
nothing there the coach is wrong or
we're being physically outplayed by
another team and those are the things
that I see that the guys in front of
Brees are better at at this point and
it's not a knock on Brees he's a little
older he needs a system and a team
around him again this is Drew Brees and
we're going awful last year but I've
never seen people stick up for a
quarterback who's only been to the
playoffs twice in the last like six
years but but nobody wants to talk about
that so I'm not gonna blame him for that
because I know their team wasn't that
great around him but you can't then
again tell me he's great because the
team was good this year and now it's not
5-quart I mean I was downstairs
defending Russell Wilson people like I
can't believe he's in the top five and
I'm like I if you can't see what Russell
Wilson has then we can't talk because
you're not this is my new philosophy my
new philosophy is people are Instagram
first NFL later huh they watch the games
and they say they're watching the game
but they're talking to their friends
they're looking at social media then I
hear touchdown breeze I go man Drew
Brees is the best yeah and then they
look back down and they're not looking
at anything else I think you don't know
what you have the right to do that yeah
we'll watch for you right just will tell
you who's good I am go ahead what do you
want
so excited I also just wanted to say the
gun to your head list yeah let's do
God's reference yesterday right in my
mind is a totally different list if it's
a gun to your head that's a flash genes
yeah one drive to win the game sure Tom
Brady okay great I get that this is
we're building a team here what
quarterback do we want to have for this
season for this season and for everybody
out there like I truly try to go into
this and evaluate it like like left go
is just saying you guys wanna watch it
have fun I've been taught the sport by
some really smart people I've been
around it and I'm not trying to stand on
my high horse
I'm truly trying to just tell you
honestly through my evaluation what I
think and am I wrong as drew Brees three
spots out of that I don't know Bill
Belichick might go no Chris Simms is
wrong he's the number six quarterback or
whatever I understand that I'm not
saying speaking of Drew Brees I want to
start off with free agencies is so
excited but I spoke I want to start off
with the podcast talking about where the
quarterbacks went and we'll talk about
what those teams did but I think a lot
of this free agency was defined early on
by where the quarterbacks going to go
drew Brees stuck around goes to the
Saints by the way they also signed Tom
savage Saints he's getting a two-year
fifty million dollar deal twenty seven
guaranteed so it's pretty much a
one-year deal and we'll see what happens
next year but they're going for the
title they're going for it see what they
can do which they should yes and yes
it's what the deal I expected and it's I
give drew Brees like a lot of respect
for not holding their feet to the fire
going
I need 30 million because Kirk Cousins
got this when I saw Zach Strief strife
retirement ceremony right he was crying
and talking about how incredible Drew
Brees was right the one thing I will say
about the list if you're talking about
just picking a guy out of a lineup and
we're doing a backyard football right
Brees and Brady are gonna have instant
respect and they're gonna organize these
guys and that's maybe not something you
see on film right but I know Brees is a
big lifter
he's a locker room chief he's another
coach out there no III think he deserves
that respect yeah but that wasn't
we're talking about I just want to get
that out there I don't know people think
we're disrespecting drew we're not
timely yes I'm not disrespect what he's
doing it his age is still I mean his arm
really hasn't declined he never had a
great norm but it hasn't really declined
and then the fact that he can still move
around and make noise a little bit it's
phenomenal it's like when you say bolt
turns 40 he's still Usain Bolt right I
bet she's still fast but at 40 we're not
gonna go why doesn't he get out there
and beat these dudes in the Olympics
right it's like no cos they're 23 and
he's 40 is he faster than us yes is he
still really good is what he's doing it
40 amazing right but he going out there
with this new 23 year old whiz kid right
that's evolution like just do like this
is I think Russell Wilson is they
perfect okay example of like if trying
to prove our point if we sat down with
our audience I think and watch the
Seattle Seahawks Wilson the answer is
always you just need to watch him yes if
we watch the film with us and we got to
sit there and watch it and they go oh my
gosh they would realize what a disaster
the offense is how he never has block
yeah and so my question and my question
I thought I'd do people think that Drew
Brees could survive in that offense I
think they do I just that's what I'm
trying to like that's what I I'm trying
to look at the opposite I would want to
show them Saints film and show how open
guys are under a Seahawks film and show
how not open and then also time in the
pocket right people don't realize the
scenes had one of the top two offensive
lines in the NFL last year I mean they
don't number one rushing attack on the
sport all right we've done enough yeah
Kirk Cousins number one guy going to the
Vikings they also traded for Trevor
Simeon in Minnesota victory but three
years 84 million all guaranteed we are
the players podcast we have been wanting
different contracts like this for years
yeah what did Kirk just do for the
future
get my universe I mean he's he's
breaking barriers for pliers I mean he
really is he's gonna be in a lot of ways
I think when the history is all said and
done Kirk Cousins gonna be a little bit
remembered for being one of the first
ones to attack free agency as a player
like a fabulous man right he is he's
gonna be them one of the first ones to
talked about in that conversation three
eighty-four million again it seems like
a lot of money for a guy that yeah
certainly I don't think he's one of the
five best quarterbacks or ten best
quarterbacks but again I'll say this
okay
the rate for starting quarterbacks in
football I mean we were seeing Case
Keenum
we got 18 million a year that's he's
considered a low level Sam Bradford's
bone-on-bone he's getting 20 million a
year so he's 28 doesn't get 20 so it
don't be mad and again I don't know what
it is but the 9th guy in the bench of
basketball is allowed to make 20 million
dollars but starting quarterbacks in
football or any football players not
allowed to make money because it's
because of one phrase Kirk Cousins is
now the highest-paid player in the NFL
and every football fan and they'd be
right because he's not the best in the
NFL no and there's a disconnect because
in the NBA only the true elite guys are
getting the most and it's that title and
I think you know people look at Kirk
Cousins and they're like maybe if I
tried harder in high school football I
could have done that
oh he studies really hard I should have
studied harder I think it's because he's
attainable I think people look at Cam
Newton they go I never could do that no
they look at Kirk Cousins and they go he
looks like Johnny average white guy I
think I could have done that if I was
just a little more dedicated and didn't
hit the beer funnel so hard I knew you
guys was behind that guy at Subway two
days ago like that's Kirk Cousins more
props to him yes more props to him and
again you can't look at it that way with
the NFL the way the rules are set up
with free agency in the cap and all that
we need guys to always go he's the new
highest pay that's the only way the
players are gonna continue to get money
I mean look at Erin Donald right now
Erin Donald is the best player on the
defensive side of football and we're
going wait did you just say that for
real yeah I mean he's certainly up in
that conversation okay don't let your
Fletcher would be my first pick at
d-tackle all right we have to start a
new list
I was regardless you got a I just again
the old saying like it's the only
profession in the world hey you're the
best of what you do but we're not gonna
pay you for the best of what you do
until you're declining and then we're
gonna find a way to [ __ ] you over and it
was past five minutes
and we'll find a way to that was great
now like now you're [ __ ] frazzle
how much closer the Vikings to a Super
Bowl with Kirk Cousins instead of Case
Keenum not a ton more Wow
so then what about the Broncos gettin
Case Keenum for literally more than half
the price yeah I mean it's it's good
business by the Broncos I think it tells
you the Broncos - we're gonna it for my
money it tells me that they're out of
the quarterback conversation at number
five in the draft because what I mean
really you got a two year deal I know so
it is it's a two-year deal
I get that you're still doing them
Paxton Lynch right and you got the kid
that they think's talented - they're
Chad Kelly I mean they think chad has
big-time talent so all that together and
then the fact that we know this team is
closer than their record appeared last
year they were pretty yeah I mean the
games where we going man they're kind of
dominating the game physically but
there's a block fumble I mean a fumble
on a punt returner send me in through a
dumb interception they lose to leave
they lose a bunch of guys they did just
restructure Chris Harris jr. they still
have another first-round corner who's
very rolling exactly right you know they
have the Simmons kid at safety they
brought back Tom Davis
and they just restructured Von Miller
props to Vaughn getting 16 base getting
immediately signing bonus I love when
players get immediate cash it's awesome
are they gonna be in the Adamic ensue
sweeps they to get to that in a little
bit okay Sam Bradford to the Cardinals
yeah one year twenty million dollars 15
guaranteed he's made now like over a
hundred and thirty million dollars is he
the answer for the Cardinals are they
making the right move investing as him
as the guy I think they're stuck in a
spot where they're stuck in I think they
want to draft a quarterback but where
they are in the draft where do they end
up in 12 I gotcha okay thanks yeah I
think they're stuck in that spot to go
damn we might get left out in the cold
and not get a quarterback in the draft
that lease might trade exactly right I
mean the bill is it setting up for that
at least in my mind so you look at that
and then they go okay well we'll get
Bradford cuz he's got talent okay he
does have talent and that's why everyone
out there for the people go man he gets
paid for doing a lot of nothing I
understand that it has not been a great
career and he's teen fifth pick 15 right
so that's no man's land for this year
and the quarterback and I think you know
but Bradford when you watch the film
from two years ago against the Minnesota
but when he was on the Minnesota Vikings
I played all year he threw 20 touchdown
six interceptions yeah he's one of the
highest-rated quarterbacks of highest
quarterback percentage in the history of
the NFL for that size a completion
percentage that's right the year before
that he was good only he was he was good
so quarterback coaches and OCS leave Sam
Bradford and go I'd coach him again yes
he's so well respected well and you when
you see him on the field this is the one
thing that everybody always says he look
it looks like a good ball I mean it's in
it's a lot it's a lot stronger arm than
TV does it justice to so I think he
Wow's people and then the word gets out
and then there's a film to go along with
it and Arizona's probably watched them
in warm-ups before and they're again he
can really throw it so they bring him
there and then they bring a great
insurance policy with Glennon behind him
yes because Bradford is an injury hazard
we know that they've also signed Andre
Smith but they also cut honey badger
yeah this looked like the future of the
Cardinals back when Todd Bowles was the
DC we're gonna go multiple safeties
we're gonna be really hard to game plan
against Tyrann Mathieu on the open
market yeah where are we thinking what
do you want where you want him to go how
good is he still yeah Jordans I mean all
right so let's start with that how good
is he so I don't think he's worth the
price tag he was gonna get in Arizona
since he hurt his knee that second time
in the game right bonding that game was
awful Monday or Thursday he has not been
as good since then he is not now
this will be your - coming up after that
interests or maybe he gets back to his
normal self but I can tell you from
watching him film last year that Arizona
defense was good but he certainly was
not making the amount of plays he was
prior to that injury still top top half
of the NFL starting safety yes okay he
is but I mean he was legitimately in the
conversation from one of the best
secondary players of course he was
insane so where could he go I mean the
Jets Todd Bowles drove it up so you
would have a Jamal Adams Marcus may
honey badger triumphant with Tremaine
Johnson because a honey badger could
play nickel and they got the money they
got the money alright James Becher's is
Aldi coordinator so two former coaches
Giants and the Jets in New York no doubt
that's pretty good gun to your head gun
to my head and other teams what do you
want to say
yeah oh that's right it says exactly
right he does have a child with Todd
balls great daughter right it's Todd
balls daughter right josh is gonna
confirm I don't know if they're married
no it's I know he has a kid I don't that
raises another question right do you
want to play for your father and I don't
think so
Kris needs to call Kris need to say how
did that work out without Tom Coughlin's
yeah Todd Bowles Tom Coughlin's being
your father-in-law holy crap he doesn't
carry he's not gonna show you any prey
Chris great Todd balls daughter
yes his daughter right I don't know if
they're married or if they or not
they're not but either way that makes
sense to me right well let's so you know
so those two teams make sense definitely
I want to move to the Jets yeah because
their quarterback situation they were
gonna be in the Kirk Cousins but now
they end up with Josh McCown one year 10
million teddy bridgewater one year up to
15 million we'll get to the rest of the
team what do you think the Jets are
planning to do at quarterback this isn't
the end I don't think they drafting a
quarterback at six I don't think so I
don't know I don't know what the Jets
are doing right now I really don't I
mean it sounds like there's a lot of
parts of Teddy Bridgewater's contract
that it prevents the team it protects
the team yes that if he does well great
if not it's not that much he has did a
lot of qualifiers so from my point
what's the base value of it I got a look
at I think it was in the sixes or seven
it was in there but I'm ready sure that
it looked in my mind it looks like
they're going maybe Teddy's the guy if
not Josh gets us through right but the
whole time I still thought they were
gonna take a quarterback it's sick and I
don't know if that totally takes them
out of that conversation all together
but I know there was people in that
organization that were completely fine
with Josh McCown coming back and being
the holdover guy for whoever they pick
at number six and when that time comes
that's what some people in the
organization thought was going to happen
is what you're saying yes right and now
are they confused too I think so when
I'm confused too and you know at number
six they're in they're in danger zone
too we're still gonna get one of those I
get one of them but there might not be
one of the ones they want right I mean
if they get stuck with quarterback
number four or five on their draft board
they might go dim we're not gonna take
him at pick number six and we have we
like this guy here and we don't want him
to be our quarterback channel if the guy
that Felda them there so I think they
have options here I know I want to look
at the 34 I want to look at the teddy
bridgewater details cuz I think that's
gonna find Graham they also signed
Isaiah Crowell and they get shermaine
Johnson yeah coupling up Jermaine with
Jamal Adams and Marcus may what kind of
a secondary are we going to see in New
York next season as good as it good as
it gets I mean Tremaine Johnson you know
I love him is he like your perfect
Island Corner lexan he's a really big
guy that changed directions stuff it
might not be on par with some of the
other top corners in football but it's
really close the thing I like about him
is I do think it's pretty good for a guy
his size his size his strength his
ability to turn and run are all
top-notch to me I was told that I think
the Jets were trying to get Malcolm
Butler and shermaine Johnson I've been
Butler Johnson and then those two young
save yes right
so go ahead it's five million in base
for Teddy but he can make up to 15
million so five million in base nothing
it is I bet you that extra 10 million is
about playing time Awards so fell off to
him ended up being there if they're if
they siliceous it let's just throw my
name out there say Josh Allen they want
Josh on he ends up being their number
six somehow
Teddy could be in trouble he might just
five million dollars yeah nothing he
might be just third string five million
or they might just gonna factor in
adjust the Jets came in with the
second-most cap space so they can afford
they can if it doesn't make end but I
find that unlikely I think they keep him
around on that nonetheless AJ McCarron
yeah to the bills two years ten million
six point five possible in bonuses so
they got him on the cheap right does he
fit what they wanted to do in Buffalo we
talked about how Sam Bradford fit yeah
Karen he does because again connect the
dots like Brian day ball New England guy
came from Alabama Oh AJ McCarron's from
Alabama so he's that type of system guy
they're gonna trust him because he's a
saving God and we starting next year if
they move up a drink right to me the way
that contract set up they are definitely
moving up the trade they are taking a
quarterback
that to me is hands down there's no way
everything screams quarterback there so
I love what Shawn McDermott did last
year I love what he's doing now I agree
they came in with a plan and it seems
like they're doing the Eagles plan they
got the defense a little bit sorted out
offense a little bit more focused now
they're gonna move up just like the
Eagles did to probably take a
quarterback I just trust Shawn McDermott
as I said it last year before the year
when he was talking about competition
and no [ __ ] and it actually worked
during the year I got faith in that guy
you should he's got a plan and he's
gonna hold his team and he does he's got
a good eye for talent and he knows what
he wants for his football team he's
funny that to assistance under Andy Reid
that got a lot of [ __ ] Doug Peterson and
Shawn McDermott when they were like OCS
and DC's for Philadelphia are now
seemingly having success as head coaches
under that Reid coaching tree yeah which
i think is a Holmgren coach it is the
holmgren tree they also need the Bill
Walsh tree so bills remember they got
rid of what's-his-name that went to the
Jaguars Darius Wright well they get star
luteal a Lee and they Reese I'm Kyle
Williams that defense will be good again
yes they needed size in the middle
that's their number one issue and I
still think they're probably gonna need
another player or two with size in the
middle though that's right their run
defense was a concern I mean we talked
about it during the end of the season
remember I mean I think Kyle Williams
was the only 300 pounder they had on the
roster until they called up one one guy
you know from the practice squad
basically like the biggest guy in the D
line was 295 and then they won a 1b they
wonder why the New Orleans Saints ran
for 300 yards on them right so this was
a huge move he drafted low to lay lay
that makes a lot of sense yes I mean
it's gonna be a perfect scheme fit and
exactly what they needed I'm out have a
great pocket is it let's try and keep
this under two and a half hours then
cool perfect yeah cool let's go then to
our favorite coach in the NFL Kyle
Shanahan and the 49ers who had the
fifth-most cap they make Weston Richburg
a very rich man paying them 47 and a
half million twenty eight and a half
guaranteed and then they go out there
and they pay seven and a half million a
year for Jerick McKinnon right these two
guys you know Kyle better than anybody
they fit the scheme Richburg in the
middle is he playing center or guard and
then jerk McKinnon yeah I know which
Richards playing Center Richburg I think
Kyle values the center position or they
just gave into it yeah I think Kilgore
will be the guard swing backup center or
whatever they got to do there that's
what I would look at it that as I know I
think I told you I mean I knew these
were the two guys Kyle had told me like
this was the two guys you guys spoke on
the phone and he was very excited about
these two he was I couldn't I kept my
mouth shut it I'm impressed thank you
but yes he had told me that he was
willing to even overpay for those two
why Weston Richburg What did he say
about it well what some Richburg I think
he's just when you watch him you're
gonna be so impressed with his
athleticism I mean that's the really the
big thing for him to make some of the
blocks that Kyle needs in his zone
Shanahan scheme it's a lot of pressure
and then when you really look at Kyle
through his career he's had really good
center play I was gonna say how does
Weston Richburg at this point compared
to an Alex Mack who he had so much
success with an L he's more athletic
than Alex math he's not I don't think is
strong at the point of attack as Alex
Mack like Alex Mack that's the one thing
that just he gets it done like with like
ya what your [ __ ] can be over him and he
might be like blocking him with his back
in his shoulder and turned around but
Fletcher Cox isn't gonna make the tackle
but Westin is the kind of guy where he
could pull a center and we're like I'm
more of a Travis Kelce kind of guy but
with the maybe a little more meat in his
ass why is Jerick McKinnon a better fit
for that offense than Carlos hi I think
the past game stuff is really the
biggest thing that I would imagine I
didn't get into like the specifics about
what he said he told me he goes out
really like Jeremy McKenna I said yeah
he'd be perfect on your offense and he
was like yeah I think so too
because Kyle those type of running backs
again I think or do you got almost look
at them like slash slot receivers that's
how he can use them coming out of the
backfield
I mean Juicy J Kyle Jew stick out of the
backfield now right it's gonna have to
worry about bootlegs option routes with
either one of them coming out against
linebackers all those things we talked
about alas like I mean what's the point
of acquiring receivers right now against
going against the Rams until even Peters
get tight ends and running backs and
just work the middle of the field then
because you're not gonna win on outside
quarterbacks you're not gonna be
comfortable but you have good one who
could hold him deep I think a lot of
Niners fans wanted another wide receiver
yeah but I don't think it was their
Niners just be patient
be patient Sammy Watkins 48 millions it
was not worth it to me and I think
that's Kyle kind of had that same
feeling and Alan Robinson the price he
demanded too I mean he's worth that when
he's healthy but he's coming off an ACL
injury and I don't think that's
necessarily Kyle's kind of scheme fit
type of guy let's salute two guys that
are hanging them up Joe Thomas don't we
call puzzle doesn't he officially
retiring and I want to say to both of
these guys I get it yeah your body's
talking to you right now I it sucks
yeah that Jaguars and Browns for both of
these guys career have been
bottom-of-the-barrel bumps and then
right when they're about to like start
making moves
definitely the Jaguars they gotta call
it quits all I know is it was really fun
talking to Joe Thomas when he came on
our podcast yeah I know that him and
Hawk are gonna do great with a tomahawk
podcast Paul puzzling is one of just the
realest he'll probably get into coaching
he cut or TV cuz he does this issue and
he's Johnny handsome I mean he's like is
he oh my gosh Johnny is he a Josh McCown
Chen without a doubt like like those
Chin's that makes you feel less of a man
because his chin is old he's like he is
he's like he's like male model blue
steel Paul puzzle doesn't yes he is he
really is a double ping yes he is he is
he has that total I wouldn't be shocked
if we saw both of them in the TV
business at some point Joe Thomas is
such an awesome guy Murray around
yes hall-of-famer I'm not gonna say he's
first ballot but he's a hall-of-famer
for sure and the thing that I really
appreciate about Joe Thomas more than
anything is he was he danced a very fine
line of being very honest and kind of
being the team spokesman without ever
overdoing it or being a distraction yes
when I was in even like production
meetings of them when I was covering
games on CBS and stuff Joe Thomas when
they'd always go who do you want to talk
to it he was the first guy I wasn't
asked cuz I knew I was gonna get useful
information at a joke Thomas I was gonna
ask him about Pires on his own team and
he was gonna give me you know I mean I
don't know if you could sit under you
didn't say this on TV but I mean this is
our best linebacker that and I can go
yeah okay okay good he can give you
little Inklings of what's going on
behind the scene which I really
appreciate it and of course he was an
amazing player
uh to the Browns though they added Chris
Hubbard from the Steelers and offensive
lineman I they get Donald Stevenson as
well nice they get a defensive lineman
and Chris Smith they get a safety and TJ
Carey and they also speaking of the
Niners get Carlos Hyde getting Carlos
Hyde chief Johnson does this take them
out of drafting sake one at number one I
do think it does damn I know I know
that means the Giants a good have said
God why is gonna be funny after sake
Juan why go by say quad why do you think
they went Carlos Hyde here I'm guessing
the D value of the running back position
and they just felt like we got other
things that we would rather put our
resources to in the draft and we'll go
Carlos Hyde who can do a little bit of
everything and we have do Johnson to be
the past catcher out of the backfield
right I just think that's at the end of
it's the only way I can justify on both
sides a Buckeye he wanted to come home
to Cleveland to Ohio another angle
certainly you like that though should
they have gone sake one over Carlos Hyde
is this something they're gonna regret I
think they might damn I mean I'd have a
hard time passing up sake one I I'm
telling you I'm just telling you yeah
you're just like man it's like it's like
you talk about him like a lost love
you're like I was 14 and she was my age
and I've never felt that again state did
not block for this kid and when they do
think now you think the Giants are gonna
go say Kwan I I just I don't know how
you can pass them up I don't know how
you can do it I know that the Eagles
have a Super Bowl ring but knowing that
I'm might be playing against Odell and
say Kwan o CT talk about the track like
what do you do it's 11:00 on that that's
that's what I came away with more than
anything on Penn State Penn State's
offense was good only because of one
reason number 26 was such a focal point
and every defense was so scared of he
would come out of the backfield and like
safeties and linebackers would go run
and cover him and then there were you
know wide open receiver down in the
middle and you beg damn how'd he get so
open you'd be like well [ __ ] three guys
went to co cover say Quan cuz it does
everything for them Simms let's talk
about our favorite team in the NFL the
New York Giants know the Jacksonville
Jaguars yes they are our favorite team
I know and it's funny because last week
we talked about GM David Caldwell having
that one quote saying I haven't made
life easier for Blake bortles is that
nice for him he was right to protect
your quarter at the same point you
talked about all the draft picks and the
wide receivers and all that stuff right
well he's doing stuff for Blake bortles
they go from Indy and they get Donte
Moncrief they resize Marcus Lee they pay
Andrew Norwell sixty six and a half
million with 30 guaranteed to play guard
they also go and they get Niles Paul at
tight end and there are rumors right now
that they're talking to Austin Safari
and Jenkins so you you mix that in with
what they have with Leonard fournette
it's gonna be an interesting year
watching bortles because he's gonna have
the offense of mind and the weapons and
a good offensive line in front of him if
Blake bortles was your quarterback and
if he was my quarterback which I would
not want him to be but if he was this is
the way you build the team around him
they're gonna run the ball yes they're
gonna run bootlegs Donte Moncrief can go
up and catch jump balls Royals Paul is a
really good athletic tight end which is
gonna help the bootleg game again we got
a lot of time to write all that kind of
stuff exactly right you get it Austin
Safari and Jenkins Marcus Lee so it's
familiarity needs great across the
middle and the roll out exactly right
build a phenomenal is a good fire yes I
love that they're going for a Super Bowl
I do too
they think that they're in their window
they're spending a little bit right now
I'm a little bit worried that they're
not you know locking up some of these
defensive guys long-term but they're
trying to win a Super Bowl next year
they need to that I appreciate that
agree this is not every team goes for a
Super Bowl no this is their two-year
window it's this year next year I mean
it's it's prime now maybe they do it
after that that certainly could happen
but I'm just saying the way their team
is set up right now like we said and you
we know and we've just wax poetically
about them the whole year they're the
most fun physically gifted team to watch
in football and no matter how ugly the
game is I love it I love watching them
play yeah it's like watching the Legion
of boom in its prime to me it feels like
that's what it is it's just like hey
we're out here we do this and we're
gonna kick your ass because we're so
good at this I don't even care if you
right here with letter for that tackle
them well in addition to being like the
quarterback guru and all of your
rankings next year talking about Blake
bortles will be one of the most
interesting things I think we've ever
experienced enter of that look we're
rooting I hope Blake bortles may becomes
the fiftieth best quarterback in the NFL
I think I really do he has the team
around him right now he does alright
let's go to the most interesting
signings and this is the category that I
call offensive masters get weapons
first one Matt Nagy becomes the head
coach of the Chicago Bears and here is
who he added wide receiver Allen
Robinson wide receiver from Atlanta this
speedster that Kyle used Taylor Gabriel
and the tight end from the Eagles that
threw the touchdown on the Philly
special to Carson Wentz Trey Burton yeah
Trey Burton I felt a video from two
years ago in the preseason and you said
he's a young Jordan Reed so that's who
they add there with big old Adam Shaheen
yeah so you have a two tight end set
right you have Taylor Gabriel to take
the top off Allen Robinson tarik Cohen
and Jordan Howard and maybe Kevin white
and maybe got I forget I know right oh
my god it's crazy with Mitchell Travis
key yeah what are you excited about with
Matt Nagy and these weapons I just think
it's a it's the again it he's building
the offense the way he should for what
he wants to do with a scheme and true
Biscay who's a more gifted version of an
Alex Smith right he's faster he's got a
bigger arm he's more aggressive in his
decision-making in the pocket
yeah Burton can be shovel pass Travis
Kelce Oh lead block from us cent time to
time line up with slot receiver him be
people man-to-man and then you got Allen
Robinson on the outside what do you what
are what are healthy expectations for
you for Allen Robbins ice I still think
the fact that he got hurt in Week one
last year he's gonna be very close to
being his total self you know I always
say year two is always the year you get
there but he is like a guy look at a
week one he can be around 90 95 percent
he's never been someone that's just
gonna absolutely burn by you with speed
but he's a really good route runner he
guys tremendous ability to go up and get
the ball in 50/50 balls and he's also a
big body to where you could throw the
ball over the middle and so he can do a
little bit of everything in the past
game is he perched
to be better than Al Shean yeah guys
like just an overall player yes I do I
think he's a better he's not of course
not as big but yeah I think he is when
he is healthy is a better all-around
player than al Shawn Jeffrey really from
all facets other than just the size
factor and then you said it like with
Taylor Gabriel
you know he's their poor man's Tyree
kill hay mid the Safety's those corners
they're all gonna back the hell off when
they see him in a tight split they're
gonna go damn and he's gonna run them
deep down the middle and then it's gonna
be Trabert and wide open over the middle
but you expected a big year for Mitchell
and then I do I think people you know
just the people I've talked ah go it has
to back off Mitchell true Brisky they're
a little critical of him when I talk to
like radio people there's everything man
the least talented offense in football
last year so I don't up sorry it's time
to break in we have breaking news here
former Bears guard Josh Johnson is going
for a two-year deal to who Chris than
Giants nope okay we've literally been
playing this for the last two days he's
going to the Miami Dolphin he is
apparently gonna be on that offensive
line now but Josh sitting in that gay
scheme do you think I mean sit-ins still
good player he's not well no it's it's
coming he's going like this he's on the
on the falling down part of his career
now you know it's Chicago he was
expendable there Chicago's got a great
offensive line when they're healthy I
mean he was only brought there because
they got a bunch of people hurt remember
two years ago and they had to get him
across Sioux and all right yeah you know
they still got Kyle long they got the
cure the kid they drafted at a Kansas
State with a white head all right was
that his name white hair right here and
right corner you white hair exactly
right how could you forget that yes so
they have that wait here but yeah this
is funny how do you do this we're gonna
talk about the dolphins now so the
Dolphins let Jarvis Landry go right and
they bring in slot wide receiver
Supremes Albert Wilson Danny Amendola
and they pretty much paid those two guys
about what Jarvis Landry is would make
right now they bring in Josh sittin and
they obviously cut in Douma can sue but
that offense with Kenny Stills Amendola
and Albert Wilson I mean that Vontae
Parker and Devante Parker but that bunch
formation of those three slot receivers
Adam GaSe I mean that's what he was
doing with Sanders and all those guys in
Denver exactly right wes welker yeah
cases like cases the start of that next
level of guys we like when you talked
about the the like the Mount Rushmore of
offensive coordinator McDaniels he said
that next year next year he is he's that
next group would I really write my
offensive masters getting weapons yeah
got it and that's it that's what he is
he really is so yeah he is building
something there and I think again it
it's it's more about the culture too
he's trying to get guys that he likes
and he thinks that are gonna fit the way
he wants to coach the football team he
is a tough ass I've said that to you yes
and you know dealing with a Jarvis
Landry contract situation and Sue and
all that
I probably stepped on really the way he
wants to act as a team player all
together but that's a good signing by
them I mean they do need help at the
guard position that's been an issue
you like that wide receiver core though
I do Albert Wilson is not gonna be as
good as Jarvis Landry after the catch
but he's gonna they're gonna be able to
do more with him really some yes
Jarvis when you play when Albert Wilson
gets people to play him man-to-man he
has more ability to run by than the
Jarvis Landry does now he's a true slot
receiver just like Landry but no he's a
good player he's gonna be it's gonna be
perfect the way they got to make sure
thing about the Dolphins my man Devante
Parker yes I love this kid he is what's
gonna determine how big that office is
because he's the guy that makes the big
play and all those dudes are gonna keep
the offense clicking down the field
I still like their running backs people
are sleeping on Kenyans rig yes Kenyan
Drake is gonna be a big he was amazing
the was amazing you just want to make
him make sure he keeps climbing the
ladder here year by year the other
offensive master getting weapons the
Chiefs right Andy Reid
their offense now reads Tyree kill
Travis Kelce Kareem hunt and Sammy
freakin Watkins on the outside getting
30 million guaranteed they also got
Anthony Hitchens which we love it
linebacker awesome but that offense it
reminds me of when Andy had the 2010
Eagles when he had Vick
LeSean McCoy Jeremy Maclin and DeSean
Jackson and a young Zach Ertz
I look at this team Kel
see is the Earth's Macklin and Deshawn
Jackson that's gonna be Tyreke L and
Sammy Watkins and then Kareem hunt back
there what do you think about this
Chiefs offense and Patrick mother-effing
mahomes right mahomes who can I just
look at the Chiefs and I go Sammy you go
on that side
Tyreke you go on that side Patrick can
out throw both of you just run if either
of you get open great if not Kelsey's
across the middle and I got Kareem hunt
in the backfield right I don't know how
you defend that office D Anthony Tom
yeah Anthony Thomas is slot receiver
exactly right no it's it was it's the
perfect type of player do I think they
overpaid for Sammy Watkins a little yes
I do I mean that's that was a lot of
monies being paid like he's one of the
five best receivers in football I don't
believe he's that but that's cool
whatever he does fit a specific role for
their team and what they need I you know
you said they like to just Shawn Jackson
Jeremy Maclin man I'd take these two
over that could that too really I would
yes because Sammy I mean the one thing
he can still do is he still can run by
he can run by people he's not like as
fast as he was coming out of Clemson I
think that's part of the reason he got
paid really as people are still hoping
to see the guy they saw Clemson but
we're like three lower leg injuries
after that now I don't know if that's
coming back I mean with him and Tyreke
like you said you said it you're right
that's that's what you do I would just
say go they're gonna put them on the
outside and they're gonna put teams in a
predicament the Chiefs are gonna try to
outscore teams next year like 45 to 35
not be shocked they're definitely one of
the teams I'm most excited to watch just
be unveiled that's all my the offensive
master is getting weapons Hitchens is it
great signing a middle linebacker they
they've been doing Derek Johnson wrong
for too long yeah they need help in the
middle yeah now this is my Patriots
players going elsewhere and you have a
theory hmm your theory about Patriots
players leaving why is there seemingly
an exit and we never see an exodus of
this level yeah you know and my biggest
theory is I just think a lot of the guys
up there probably listen I know this a
little bit they feel underappreciated
they feel undervalued they're sick of
like oh I'll sign back with the Patriots
because I know we're gonna win and we're
gonna get playoff checks and we're gonna
get notoriety and I can be a part of
Bill Belichick and Tom Brady yeah okay
but at some point you got to get paid
and you got
turned out you can't turn down the money
in the business of football for a player
that the careers are so short yes oh I'm
sure they low-balled Dion Lewis let's
talk about the Titans yeah so the Titans
get to ya and remember their coaches
Mike Vrabel alright and their GM is John
Robinson their OC is Matt Lafleur who's
from the McVeigh Shanahan offense so
they need a running back that can come
out I was just saying that for Abel and
John Roberts has both come from the
Patriots so they know those guys and
those guys clearly felt comfortable
right Dion Lewis and Malcom Butler
apparently he wasn't too much of an
issue in the Super Bowl if he's getting
five from 61 with 30 million guarantee
man you know they got the story I mean
you know John Robinson or a ball heard
what happened they found out so they
obviously weren't that disgruntled about
it to go it's becoming more and more an
ego play by Belichick and it's the rare
time that he lets that happen or is he
really just doesn't care and he's
protecting Malcolm Butler maybe Malcolm
baller really did something wrong right
I don't know but Malcolm Butler joins
Logan Ryan back there so now you have
like an all Patriots secondary and
they've needed secondary help for a
while to Tory Jackson and oh and Kevin
by yard whoo yes I do like the pairing
of Dion Lewis and Derek Henry as well
yeah I saw some people on PFF saying
that Dion Lewis is a he and every down
back and I'm like I don't know he's just
a good partnership yes in the NFL how
can people not realize that the Eagles
had four running backs in the Superbowl
right the Patriots had four running
backs in the Superbowl right I mean we
see James White in the Superbowl against
the Falcons we don't even see them for
the next nine games after the regular
season and so yes your rivals a je Corey
Clemens LeGarrette Blount they then they
still have what's-his-name a few other
guys whatever it's it's an important
part what do you think about the Titans
though their moves their moves you're
gonna make moves in the playoffs
Christmas well yeah man you got to play
to Sean Boston and the Jaguars and
Andrew Luck's coming back and now they
got those three guys a corner Logan Ryan
Malcolm and Butler a Dori Jackson that's
it's it's phenomenal and then you know
if Corey Davis can pan out on offense
for them him with Delanie Walker and now
with Dion Lewis to add to that you know
again Matt Lafleur's from the Mikve
Shanahan coaching school who was led the
Rams and receiving this year Todd Gurley
out of the backfield this is
what they're gonna use the Lewis for it
it's just widens Shanahan signed Jerick
McKinnon so you're gonna see a lot of
those same type of things
speaking of Patriots players going
somewhere else yeah maybe the biggest
one
Nate's older yeah Nate's older leaves
the Patriots the left tackle when you
really look at the Patriots over the
years whether it was matte light they've
always kind of Sebastian Vollmer yeah
and and solder they've always had a left
tackle or a good tackle the big German
and the big Russian yes that's what I
used to call them well he goes to the
Giants four years sixty two million
thirty-five guaranteed and they also
signed Jonathan Stewart but eight solder
you said part of the reason we thought
we'd stay with the Patriots is his son
or his child has an illness and they
he's able to get off one of the
advantages of having a team in New York
it's the best hospitals it's the best
Kerry said that right I think you did
he's clearly able to come down here they
now think they can move Eric flowers to
right tackle right but what is getting a
guy like solder change for the Giants
well I mean again he's a proving they
overpaid for solder let's just talk
about that I do think solder probably
wanted to stay in so about 15 and a half
million a year and then it's a two-year
pretty much a two-year contract yeah I
mean they're paying him like he's one of
the top tackles in football which he's
not he's not no he's not no I thought he
was no he's not he's not in the top ten
either so that to me is the thing but
what it tells me is the Giants gonna
stat on or well okay yes so they
probably said to man we have money so we
haven't been able to drip like Friday
tackle probably was like man I want to
stay in New England so that probably
forced them to baby overpay him just a
little bit but the number one thing it
just tells me is they're going with the
Giants are going all-in on this year too
they're going on and they're not gonna
drop the quarterback number smart I
don't think it is but they're in it now
I just have 38th ranked quarterback Eli
Manning yeah I mean the third of
Manning's hold the team hostage he
sounds like that's what has happened to
me the Manning's are to mercy when they
go out there right they have a really
good young tight end in Evan Engram
right they're gonna have a del Beckham
junior healthy if he plays with this
contract situation they drafts a Quan
Barkley they now have Nate's older at
left tackle they have a young sterling
Shepherd out there too
can they be good this year was it just
injuries last year and been McAdoo's
awful often yes it was injuries bad
offence and then a quarterback that
can't make plays to get the offense over
the edge I don't think Shermer and these
signings can flip it yes I do think
they're definitely gonna be a better
offense
yes there's no question just from day
one with Shermer being there I mean
Sherman's gonna give them an advantage
schirmer's gonna make them tougher he's
gonna give them a true downhill running
scheme you know that's the one thing
that annoys me a little bit about the
whole giant you know up here in New York
that's all anybody know the ovens line
was the worst of all no it wasn't I mean
Weston Richburg is just one of the
highest-paid centers in the history of
football
he's pretty friggin good Eric Flowers
wasn't bad last year he was definitely
in the top half of football of tenth
left tackles yeah a lot of people have
already written his I know so they got
to stop doing that you know Justin Pugh
when his injury situation gets all
filled out in teams feel better they're
gonna get signed for it
so the offensive line wasn't as bad as
people wanting to make it out to be it
was the system it's the fact that either
I can't move and get out of the way but
schirmer's gonna make a better job of
making life easier on Eli Manning too
and then yes the Giants watch out for
man what are you saying right now I just
think the Giants are Giants first have a
playoff caliber roster I mean they do
they did last year
and now with James bet you're a d
coordinator and Shermer I just think
they're one of those teams I look out
and go I mean don't be shocked if
they're right back in the playoffs
scarin the crap out of teams again see
that one of the lates Report app I love
what you the nice button you make news
for us it's so good other big moves
obviously the Packers yeah they bring in
Jimmy Graham they get MO Wilkerson on a
one-year five million dollar deal it
feels like when Terrance Knighton signed
with Washington for a one-year four
million and we were expecting teams to
overpay and they also cut Jordy Nelson
right bringing in Jimmy letting go Jordy
let's start off with that what do you
think of that dynamic Jimmy they needed
to do that okay as far as a tight end
play I just think with that offense it's
a it's a key part it's not that creative
so they need somebody to stress that
part of the field we thought last year
before the year we thought that
Martellus Bennett and then Adams right
what was his first name Devante no no
tight-end oh you're talking about the
tight end Adams okay bang he ended up
going yeah I went to Oakland right but
we thought with Martellus Bennett we're
like oh they could do some double tight
end stuff right now right but Jimmy
Graham is another level
Jimmy Graham's another level he's not
gonna block a whole lot so I mean that's
gonna be the one negative about it I
mean he's kind of just like get in your
way kind of blocker he's not gonna
collapse the side of the offensive line
or it's a lot anything like that but yes
he's another level of a human being
Jimmy Graham is bigger than Rob
Gronkowski I don't that's why I people
gotta realize the first time I saw Jimmy
Graham in person was when the Saints
came up to scrimmage than the New
England Patriots and I was working for
the Patriots and I just remember going
damn I just did not realize he was this
big like he's every bit as tall and he's
actually a thicker stronger man now he
doesn't play with the same physicality
but he's a mismatch nightmare for a
quarterback who has been throwing to
people that are never open anyways for
the majority of his career and now he
has a guy that's six seven and can run
and jump and he's in is gonna throw
balls I know you're covered I'll put the
ball in the corner pocket and you'll
catch it Jordy Nelson yes it was hitting
people hard and I know it's it's Roger I
mean Rodgers is upset fans I've said but
I can't justify 9 million you know they
saved nine million dollars Jordy Nelson
at this point is not worth nine million
dollars to me he's not I again is it
stink to see him go and I'm sure Aaron
Rodgers is not happy about it but it's
the best football decision for the Green
Bay Packers Jordy Nelson is no more in
that top tier he's almost like I said I
think the Oakland Raiders are gonna try
to use him like a slot receiver almost I
don't think you can depend on him to
just be the outside guy and win matchups
all game long that's not what he is and
you know so they have Randall Cobb with
the same situation where they could save
like 9 million dollars they want to get
rid of Randall Cobb too but he's younger
and he's a little more value and he
didn't just tear his ACL two years ago
so that's why they did it mo Wilkerson
for five million yeah how did that
happen because he has to prove himself
again he has a horrible reputation of
football really yes he double are
telling you that he's just not
well-received
yes well yeah because what we heard all
the off the field incidents yeah right
I've heard I'm not gonna get into like
the personal things I've heard about him
too but yeah he's been unprofessional
he is ever since he signed his big
contract for the Jets he's not been the
same guy so he's getting a one-year five
million proved to us that you can be a
professional and a player once again
being reunited with Mike Pettine who it
was with him be more than the Rex Ryan
days so he's a great system bit just
hope he can be the guy that we're used
to seeing in Donegan soon now let's get
to the guys that are still out there and
obviously this can change in the podcast
comes out but Adamic ensue what are you
hearing about suitors for him right now
everybody I mean everybody I tell I told
you before we started I made calls to a
few people about the SU thing just to
hear everybody's trying to reevaluate
the roster and see if they can fit him
in I mean not ever that's what I've seen
like restructurings all over the league
I start I think it you're gonna continue
to see that our teams are definitely
gonna be considering this because yes
he's a defense changer he's a defense
change bill yes he is he's not in the
class of Donald or Cox maybe that's the
top two that's three yeah he's he's
three four or five or whatever it is I
got a look at the hole in my D tackle we
get you in the list that's bad but but
yeah I mean okay the Browns I could see
that happening right I mean it's
certainly good the Jets could do it if
they wanted to the Colts have a ton of
money they could use em Syria or D
lineman you know I the New Orleans
Saints thing is real I know that's real
David love them the Seattle Seahawks I
think are dangling with the idea as well
but I think there's a number of teams
out there that are all looking at their
roster going how can we fit him in teams
that are all the teams that are on the
cusp that he would put them over the top
of all the teams you said okay yeah out
of all the teams I said let me pull up
the teams like him next to Miles Garrett
in Cleveland is special him on the
Saints and how they're already knocking
on the door or special yes where do you
think where do you think is the best
minute that Cowboys can find a way to
use him he's a cowboy to the Cowboys
love renegades I mean them him tire him
David Irving and DeMarcus Lawrence on
the D line yeah good luck with uh you
know what's his name the other Tyrone
Crawford holy crap I mean that'll be the
all look team so wherever sue goes is a
huge bump it's definitely a bump yes he
his issue is the huge price tag
and he's not the best leader he can be a
little bit disgruntled at times he
doesn't train there in the offseason and
that's not what teams want is they're
gonna need a leadership they want
leaders they gotta have a leader it sets
a bad example to the rest of the team to
go hey here's our highest-paid guy you
can go do whatever the [ __ ] you want now
see you later
we'll see you next season say yeah well
another guy yeah Sheldon Richards right
where do you think Sheldon's being as
Sheldon's life will be dictated by
nomicon sue everybody's gonna try to
make thousands Case Keenum they're gonna
make everybody's gonna try to go first
to go how can I make and AMA consumer
can and then if they can't they're gonna
go okay Sheldon Richardson's the next
guy in the list I gotta believe and I've
heard this a little I don't know this
for sure I got to believe he's probably
asking for too much money that's why
he's still in the market he's not I
think as good as he thinks he is
I still think Sheldon Richardson there's
a chance he goes back to Seattle I think
the number one place he goes to those in
New York Jets back I think so so they're
gonna trade get Jermaine Kearse and then
bring him back to the gym I think so I
think the money to do it he fits that
scheme and what Todd Bowles likes like
an athletic defensive tackle type who
could do everything so don't forget for
Todd Bowles he played outside linebacker
two years ago remember when they had a
bunch of injuries right he was a 285
pound outside linebacker so when he has
his head on straight he can be special
one last guy that I want to talk about
because I heard some stories about our
friend Justin Pugh and how he cares more
about barstool than he does about
football I want to tell you that
bleacher report I mean it's Barstow what
the [ __ ] just he got drafted he had a
video I went on barstool and all that
stuff but we know Justin yeah that is
not the case at all I know that to me
sounds like when you let somebody go and
you want a new story to get out there so
that it makes it look better on you guys
propaganda this dude lives this dude
like is just watching film all the time
studying see does it I know them twice a
memory he came in here like wow you
actually know the Lee he does he pays
attention all right so this is what
happens in the NFL okay this is because
I was thinking about this on the way on
the train ride in today this is what
happens I mean it's it's this
fickle at time with NFL coaches Adam and
especially if you're a first-round pick
that maybe they don't think you've lived
up to what you should be as the
first-round pick
I mean it could literally be this fickle
though just just hear me out
you could he could have one bad game and
that week of preparation during that bad
game somebody might have walked in the
online room before a meeting started and
he was looking at bar stool one of the
coaches like one time and they will
dictate the rest of his life from now
three three seconds that'll be his whole
life I mean I have coaches to me that
talk to me about things I did like in
high school sometimes and I'm gonna be
that one time you something I said or
did when I was 17 and you think I'm the
same person at 37 and yes it can be that
fickle it can really can be like you
know we were pie in the Redskins that
week and I saw him watching barstool
five minutes before the meeting and then
he didn't play good this week
that was a reason causation he's not
focused I mean it's the [ __ ] that
happens it really does I mean I've had
it happened to me I got labeled that I
know by some teams coming out of Texas
that I was though I was I'm a little bit
of a party boy I mean my friends at
Texas thought I was the biggest freaking
nerd in the world cuz I could never I
would never go out and party I mean but
like your sophomore year you got drunk
one time it's just a sixth Street one
time in my four years and I know I was
on there a lot more than that but I was
not an out-of-control party but that's
how it gets started it all as it takes
is one guy to hear one thing but I
didn't really like him on film or
whatever and I'm gonna make that my
story I'm just gonna end by saying hey
how about the Eagles I did not expect
them to re-sign Nigel Bradham that's
incredible the Haloti not a thing is a
possibility but it's not
official-official yeah but the fact that
they Reese I know Joe brought him I
thought that was a foregone conclusion
he was going I didn't think I'm glad
they let Patrick Robinson go where did
he end up New Orleans Saints back in New
Orleans really mode so many moves
happened before free agency even started
this year do you think it helped or hurt
the NFL like I had this talk with like
Florio a little bit right like we get
excited for the start of free agency but
we knew everything by Tuesday 24 hours
before free agency so then why don't we
just realize this and enjoy Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday and just
in our heads know that that's free
agency now like were you at four at four
o'clock we were in the in a taxi going
to the airport people weren't like three
two one it's the dates only matter to
the accountants whenever the moves start
happening I'm [ __ ] pumped yeah I
don't care if it's not it's not like the
New Year's ball drop actually have it on
December 28th and we're sitting here
like kind of ruined that whole calendar
change it's fine you know what I mean
like I'm down for it yeah no I it's not
horrible either I just wondering from
the NFL perspective are they botching it
the way they do it keeps only the only
people that messes up are the television
networks that have live wall-to-wall
coverage starting Wednesday at 4:00
they're the ones that it screws up well
that's right into the NFL I think that's
gonna play in the NFL's you know because
again everybody's excited for it but yet
all I hear is always a lackluster first
day of free agency no because it was an
amazing 24 hours before free agency yeah
I don't know the one thing I've learned
from being in the lab at our shows most
of the people are dumb alright guys that
is it I we got a ton of stuff in there
holy crap that was awesome yeah that was
our recap of free agency thus far there
are still a few stars out there as
always thank you for watching on the be
our Channel for everyone that is still
paying attention to my channel I'm gonna
keep posting things so you can get
notified as always hit us up on social
at Sims and left go for sibs peace out
homies vendrick would say good evening
in the lef koe man says good night
love y'all hope your team made the moves
you like and we'll holler at you soon
[Music]